the Senate plan to replace Obamacare is
already in danger right now Republicans
do not have enough votes to pass the
bill they revealed yesterday after weeks
of secret negotiations they need 50 of
the 52 GOP senators and four of them say
they're not ready to support the current
version more than a dozen leading health
and medical groups also opposes Senate
bill they include the AARP the American
Lung Association and the American
Hospital Association President Trump
tweeted this
I am very supportive and look forward to
making it really special
remember Obamacare is dead Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning
good morning well Democratic opposition
up here is universal but that is not the
key problem for GOP leaders right now
the problem is that there are holdouts
on both ends of their own party and
anything they do to win over one side is
going to jeopardize support from the
other I think that they'll probably get
there we'll have to see you know health
care is a very difficult situation
president Trump acknowledged the
Senate's health care proposal is facing
some trouble with his own party for
Senate conservatives are demanding big
changes when just three GOP no votes
would kill the bill well there are also
four good guys in the four friends of
mine we cannot support the current bill
Kentucky's Rand Paul is one of the four
I just didn't run on Obamacare alive
I didn't run on replacing it with more
government programs Senate GOP leaders
tried to strike a balance between
Obamacare which they say is failing and
a house health care bill that President
Trump called mean so the Senate bill
maintains more of Obamacare's tax
credits to help low-income Americans
afford insurance it also provides tens
of billions of dollars to bring down
premiums on Obama cares flagging
individual market and it keeps Obama
cares protections for people with
pre-existing conditions Senator Lindsey
Graham gave the bill a 50% chance of
passing the outline was promising it
does repeal the individual and employer
mandate it puts Medicaid on a more
sustainable path Medicaid emerged as a
key flashpoint Thursday inciting
protests from disabled activists the
bill would rollback Obamacare's
expansion of Medicaid and for the first
time imposed limits on federal funding
GOP moderates like Susan Collins worry
that would hurt the poor in their states
that could cause states to shrink
eligibility to cut people who really
need health care from the program
Democrats made it clear where they stand
near can you read it I have to color it
in President Obama made a pitch on
Facebook to save his signature
achievement writing that if there's a
chance you might get sick get old or
start a family this bill will do you
harm the Congressional Budget Office has
been crunching the numbers and says it
will release its independent analysis of
this bill by early next week
David Nancy thanks so much